he was honestly super happy for me and
gwen he said that if i were to lose to
anyone i'm glad it's you and gwen
um he was he was you could tell he was
truly happy for us
carter rubin have you processed that you
are
the voice season 19 winner not even a
little bit
i'm still in shock still trying to
comprehend what the heck just happened
last night
[Applause]
but i'm just so grateful and so blessed
because there's been
so many incredibly talented singers this
season and
i think my win was due to gwen's
coaching because she's
phenomenal you mark the first winner for
gwen stefani
as someone on the voice i mean this is
this is crazy first of all i can't
believe she's never won before but you
get to be that first person
for her i mean what has her support been
like for you throughout this journey
she's given me such incredible advice
that i've really taken to heart
and if i if i had a reason to win it was
definitely for her because
she is such a phenomenal caution and
it's so crazy that she hasn't won before
last night and i just really wanted to
win this for her because she deserves it
what was her reaction i know she shared
a cute instagram video where she was
like i don't know
half the words i don't i can't process
this moment but
when the cameras were all off and you
guys were able to maybe spend a moment
together what was that like what was the
the true reaction that we didn't get to
see on tv we
both did not believe what was happening
she had the same reaction as me we're
both still trying to process it like
we immediately went to press after and
uh we went and we were just both like in
shock like
we weren't crying because we were just
so in shock we didn't know
how to react we were like still trying
to
just soak it all up and take it in it
was crazy
you know gwen is someone who started her
music career when she was in her teens
and you're 15 years old you're still
very young what advice has she given you
perhaps about what's to come what is
next as you embark on your own career in
the music industry
she says that this is the perfect time
for me to start writing songs and i
completely
agree i want to keep expanding on my
music career i
plan on writing a lot of songs and
getting in the studio and recording them
and once cobit is over i want to perform
in front of live audiences again because
i
really miss the adrenaline you get from
you know a live performance what has
your relationship been like
with gwen off camera to where like when
the time comes that you do pen these
songs and you have them written
and you want some feedback are you able
to you know shoot her an email and say
hey gwen like can you what are your
thoughts on this what's your
relationship like off camera
we have we've built a very close bond
like
during like our rehearsal sessions you
only see like a minute of it and we're
in there for like an
hour and we're just she's so down to
earth and we're just
she's so genuine and we're just like
talking on the level about
you know what direction i want to go in
with the song i'm singing for
the respective week and you know i
she definitely wants the best for me
because she's worked so hard
to get to this point and he um is so
so invested in the song i'm doing she
has a big play in the song
choice um she just really
believes in me which means the world
she's in it for the right reasons you
definitely can't tell and
you know aside from that there's also
this fun aspect too where her fiance is
literally a part of
the show as well and so as much as they
love each other they also have that
competitive spirit to them
to want to beat each other what was the
reaction
or the dynamic like last night after the
win with blake especially was he a
little bitter
was he how is i know he's got to be
supportive of gwen but also he really
wants that win too
yeah he was honestly super happy for me
and gwen he said that if i were to lose
to anyone i'm glad it's you and gwen
um he was he was you could tell he was
truly happy for us
oh i love that so much so you know
honestly when you win
a part of team gwen it's almost like a
two-for-one you also
you also really get blake shelton in the
mix too
for sure for sure i love that now you
debuted your new
inspirational single up from here if we
fall
i have no fear
as long as we go down together
we can make it all from
what is next for you where do you go up
from here
good good oh good
i but it's true i want to go up from
here i want to start
writing more songs and and
creating new music for people to hear
and
the first time i listened to that song
it just sounded like something i want to
record
and that was really an inspirational
moment for me
and i want to create more songs that
sound exactly like that and
release an album and hopefully become
worldwide one day that'd be like my
dream
and um yeah just but right now i'm at
a point where like everything i want and
more is
actually happening well we we talked
about that power of manifestation and
spoken word you you look you said you
wanted to be on the show
you did it and now you said you want to
be worldwide i have
all the faith in the world for you we're
so happy for you
congratulations on everything and i
wanted to end on
a fun note because obviously when you
win the voice it's huge right it's it's
an amazing opportunity something that
you can't even comprehend but
one of the benefits also too is that
there's a prize along with it a monetary
prize and so i wanted to ask you have
you even
thought of what you would maybe reward
yourself with i know you're 15
so maybe maybe a car i don't know
maybe i haven't thought much about it
yet
um i want to spend it wisely for sure
and i want to use it for good
ah smart answer that's a good answer i
don't want to waste it
for sure here i'm like get a car you're
like no i want to do good with it
you